ja die besucher weil jetzt steht unsere
leitung nach berlin und ich begrüße dort
ganz herzlich den kollegen robert bosch
von der zeit wir haben ja vorhin live
übertragen armin laschet hat heute sein
zukunft team vorgestellt damit will er
aus dem historischen umfragetief der
union heraus ist das jetzt der große
wurf der die trendwende bringen kann die
politische konkurrenz sie spricht von
aktionismus
also ich würde sagen der aktionismus
trifft es ganz gut also die trendwende
wird das ganz sicherlich nicht bringen
über dieses zukunftsteam wurde ja schon
lange diskutiert und die forderung gab
es immer mal wieder von herrn lindemann
vom wirtschaftsflügel der union und von
anderen es ist ein thema seit monaten
und laschet hat sich immer dagegen
gewehrt hat gesagt er will kein team
weil so war immer seine argumentation
man dann eben auch sagen müsste wer
nicht dabei ist jetzt sieht man wer
nicht dabei ist das ganze kabinett ist
nicht dabei bis auf frau beherrschbaren
ist nicht dabei also offenbar ist das
zukunftsteam etwas ganz anderes als die
aktuellen mitglieder der regierung die
stehen offenbar nicht für zukunft das
kann man ja daraus lesen und das in dem
moment
wo herr laschet nun bei 20 prozent und
die union bei 20 prozent liegt dass man
dann sagt jetzt machen wir doch eine
zukunft sehen was man im vorher die
ganze zeit nicht wollte ja das zeigt die
verzweiflung der kampagne naja
vielleicht die union legt er großen wert
darauf dass das eben ein expertenteam
ist und kein schattenkabinett kommen wir
mal zu was anderen dieses historische
tief auch dass es für armin laschet
stetig in den umfragen nach unten geht
man kann das schlecht nachvollziehen
weil es heißt ja auf der anderen seite
auch die hälfte der wähler die gehe nach
inhalten es werden parteien gewählt
deshalb meine frage liegt das wirklich
nur an armin laschet dass die union so
schlecht dasteht
es sieht sicher nicht nur an armin
laschet also man kann ja auch durchaus
sehen dass die union von das ist doch
auch etwas was man in diesem zirkus team
sehen konnte dass die
zweiten und dritten reihe auch sehr dünn
sind und dass die union nach 16 jahren
regierung das sagen ja selbst
christdemokraten sagen ja im prinzip
sind wir leer wir sind fertig wir sind
ausgebrannt und das kann man in
gesprächen mit cdu land gerade sehr sehr
deutlich hören was einen dann selber
ehrlich gesagt wundert gelegentlich aber
da herrscht schon ein gewisser
fatalismus ist wäre falsch dass nur eine
person
festzumachen das glaube ich auch aber er
ist schon gerade das symbol führt diesen
niedergang und ich meine 20 prozent bei
infratest gestern das ist schon
verheerend wie bewerten sie denn die
bisherige wahlkampfstrategie der union
ich sage mal vor einem linksruck zu
wahren wo die linke in den aktuellen
umfragen gerade bei 6 prozent steht sind
denn das bisher die richtigen themen
gesetzt worden sind in diesem wahlkampf
es gab anfang der woche ein sehr
lustiges video was die die rote socken
kampagne eigentlich ganz gut
zusammenfasst war der stellvertretende
generalsekretär der csu herr hahn und
frau bär waren bei einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung und herr hahn
rief dann in die menge
wir stehen für freiheit statt
sozialismus danach totenstille und frau
bär sagte da kann man ruhig mal
klatschen also offenbar zündet ist nicht
mal bei den hardcore parteianhängern die
sich im regen zur wahlveranstaltung
stellen und das ist ja im moment das
zentrale thema das zentrale thema ist zu
warnen vor diesem linksbündnis das
linksbündnis wird nicht kommen grüne und
spd sind ja im prinzip klar sie halten
es sich taktisch als
verhandlungsspielraum weiter offen aber
es wird nicht passieren
die linke hat nichts dafür getan dass
sie irgendwie in die nähe der
regierungsfähigkeit kommen sie hat im
afghanistan-mandat nicht zugestimmt was
die goldene brücke gewesen wäre über
diese hätte drüber gehen können dass er
ziemlich gemacht und insofern ist es ein
schattenboxen was die union dort
vollführt und das jetzt noch drei wochen
weiter zu machen dafür fehlt mir die
fantasie wenn man jetzt schon merkt dass
es nicht zündet das man dann das als
quasi zentrales motiv der kampagne über
weitere drei wochen durchhält ich weiß
es ehrlich gesagt nicht das wollte sie
gerade noch anschließend dahin fragen
ist das denn jetzt der richtige
zeitpunkt dieses zukunft die ihn
vorzustellen ist es vielleicht zu spät
oder was würden sie dazu sagen
ich denke es ist in jedem fall zu spät
ich glaube man hätte darauf reagieren
können man sei ja schon vor einigen
wochen fast vor einigen monaten dass
laschet
beliebtheitswerte in den keller gingen
nach der flutkatastrophe in der gleichen
dann hätte man reagieren können und dann
hätte man
dann hätte es auch nicht so verzweifelt
ausgesehen wie es gerade wirkt also wenn
noch vor wochen dementiert wurde dass
man dieses zukunft ziehen möchte dann
gesagt wurde wir verbinden jetzt wie
gesagt die union köpfe mit konzepten und
dann gibt es noch dazu dieses
zukunftsteam also man sieht da herrscht
auch große verwirrung darüber wie das
nun genau alles funktionieren soll und
dann jetzt drei wochen vor der wahl am
tiefpunkt der kampagne
dieses zukunftsteam noch ins rennen zu
werfen respekt für jeden der mitmacht
aber es ist panik kommen wir mal in der
letzten frage nach kurzer spd also die
spd liegt in den umfragen vor der union
für olaf scholz geht es immer mehr nach
oben wie würden sie das den einschätzen
olaf scholz hat ja bisher nicht
irgendwie eine wahl mannschaft
präsentiert die er um sich scharen will
setzt das olaf scholz jetzt eventuelle
unter druck
das war ja der versuch von laschet also
der versuch war ja zum schluss sagte er
das ist unsere mannschaft wir sind
gespannt was olaf scholz für eine
mannschaft aufstellt also ich werde mir
sehr sicher dass herr scholz darauf
nicht reagieren wird und auch das ist
ein bisschen verzweifelt ehrlich gesagt
weil natürlich ist klar
die sozialdemokratie die spd ist gerade
olaf scholz und das ist das gesicht
dieses momentan höhenflugs der ein jahr
dann doch sehr überrascht aber
natürlich werden die jetzt kein team
hinstellen und es müssen sie auch gar
nicht also das team was bei laschet
jetzt steht ist ein team der
verzweifelung der panik und darauf muss
die spd jetzt nicht reagieren das wird
sie nicht sie wird das so weiter machen
wie bisher scholz wird mehr oder weniger
nicht sagen wird in den tri allen scholz
hat dort herum stehen
und hoffen dass man damit am ende vor
der union landet und im moment sieht es
ja wirklich ganz gut aus mir persönlich
fällt schwer vorzustellen dass sich
dieser trend in den nächsten drei wochen
noch einmal umgekehrt aber auch das
haben die letzten monate gezeigt da
sollte man sich nicht zu sicher sein
aber doch ist es gerade schon eine ein
deutliches momentum auf der seite der
spd ja da warten wir mal das nächste
trient sie haben das stichwort gerade
gegeben am 12 september ist dann bei ard
und zdf ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
nach berlin robert bosch war das von der
wochenzeitung die zeit
danke ihnen